en ce dimanche le président recevait des
enfants pauvres
il faut bien constater que la misère
frappe encore trop d'enfants est trop de
familles aujourd'hui avec le mouvement
aide à toute détresse qui luttent depuis
vingt ans pour aider les plus
défavorisés à sortir de la misère par un
autre moyen
aujourd'hui donc les enfants du quart
monde c'est à dire ceux des bidonvilles
expliqué publiquement ce qu'est leur
existence et quelles sont leurs espoirs
le quart monde ne se trouve pas
forcément en dehors de nos frontières en
france deux millions de personnes vivent
avec moins que le smic
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être assister
à un de ses spectacles animés par des
enfants un peu partout dans paris à 14h
ils se sont retrouvés 2000 au forum des
halles pour la première conférence
mondiale de l'enfance organisée par le
mouvement international aide à toute
détresse le thème la misère celle des
enfants du quart-monde les marginaux des
bidonvilles à 16h15 le président valéry
giscard d'estaing accueillait une
délégation de 50 enfants de neuf pays
d'europe et des états unis
ils ont présenté au président de la
république leur pétition
ce qu'ils veulent refaire un monde où la
misère n'existerait plus ici quelques
2000 personnes vivent ou survivent avec
souvent moins de 2000 francs par mois et
par famille beaucoup d'enfants
ce que les autres à l'école traite de
bane un ban dans l'argot des enfants de
reims c'est un nomade un bohémien
quelqu'un de différent et chaque jour en
classe et mes cassettes frères et soeurs
ressent cette différence ce racisme
agressive et banale des enfants parce
qu'il traite
très nous assure qu'on est des plus hot
swap à ce que nous faisons nous habille
leur ps poteau parce que nous aurons
beaucoup plus d'argent et je croyais
tout garni et ou s'ils pouvaient habiter
là où tu rêves qui habiterait ou avec un
petit jardin pour mais des fleurs c'est
sûr ils font partie des laissés pour
compte de ceux qui ont peu d'argent bien
sûr mais aussi pas de travail ou un
travail très mal payés trop d'enfants un
logement inadapté insalubres ce ne sont
pas des immigrés mais des exclus qui
vivent en marge des villes et de la
société et qui dès l'enfance au moins
que d'autres
l'égalité des chances ils ont d'énormes
difficultés par rapport aux autres
enfants ses difficultés elle démarre dès
la petite enfance à l'école maternelle
c'est des problèmes de langage des
problèmes de l'acquisition de
vocabulaire des vocabulaires beaucoup
plus prompt que la moyenne des enfants
et ces difficultés vont aller en
s'accentuant
les enfants de cette cité de transit
sont l'écho de la vie des parents fait
légal ou big voiture je fais les gallouj
fait les poubelles je ramasse à pelle
ferrals que je vends routes sont fermées
de faire les falmouth qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la vie qu'est ce que
voudriez suivi au moins que mes gosses
soigne comme comme tout le monde comme
les riches content quand je vois
a lille le lange de l'ange que ma fille
de folles fait les poubelles on en
course le large qui est balancé part
j'estime qu'elle se dote d'un cadeau
naissance d'un acte de charité entre
comme ça moi j'ai vu des affaires
repiquer encore emballés dans les
poubelles que ma fille me ramène
dépendant des services sociaux les
familles défavorisées n'arrive pas à se
prendre en charge elle-même
c'est ici que vit jakin coups par ses
deux enfants lui ont été retirés
on voulait rendre à le jour où vous
aurez un logement décent lui at on dit
mais c'est le cercle vicieux sans
travail on ne reçoit pas de logement et
sans logement ces enfants ne peuvent pas
revenir
madame raillard elle est presque une
privilégiée les sa petite maison
impeccable loué par la ville
pourtant aujourd'hui bien que ses
enfants soient presque tous adultes peu
de choses ont changé depuis des
générations les rails arts ont reçu la
misère en héritage un braillard oui il
si vous êtes plutôt mieux que vous étiez
autrefois oui on veut très bien parce
qu'on était drôlement mal logés avec 3
to petite pièce on était à onze dedans
on avait ni eau ni électricité en u16
enfants dans treize vivant
j'en ai deux décédés qu'une fausse
couche il savoir comment les deux autres
bains mort de froid
tellement qu'il faisait là on n'avait
que tu cru dans une pièce on avait trois
tout petit presse mais avec du feu dans
une pièce sait encore quoi toujours ça
marchera pas
on avait des glaçons entre aller mais
qu'est ce que faisait vos parents même
moment paire alizé d'assistance publique
ma mère était d'assistance publique et
ils ont toujours travaillé la campagne
dans la culture c'était du travail très
pénible
comment voyez l'avenir de vos enfants
qui tombe bien j'ai vu qu'ils soient pas
comme nous
est ce que quand tu seras grande tu as
envie d'avoir bon aussi beaucoup
d'enfants
oh non je voudrais en avoir qu'un seul
parce que on ne sait pas si on sera
riche ou pauvre
quand vous pensez plus à plus tard
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les choses vont bien se passer pour vous
mais moi j'ai l'impression qu'on va être
comme comme on est petit comme on part
en ce moment kerry et mireille ont des
diplômes d'ingénieur mais depuis sept
ans ils ont choisi de vivre ici dans les
mêmes conditions que les autres familles
pour aider les habitants du quartier à
s'organiser à lutter contre la fatalité
crois qu'on peut aider les enfants du
quart monde en donnant au moyen des
familles aux familles des moyens de des
moyens de vivre décemment en matière de
revenus de logements et surtout en
aidant les enfants à accéder au savoir à
sortir de l'école en sachant lire et
écrire
je crois que c'est pas seulement une
question financière c'est aussi le fait
qu' il ya une privation du savoir qui se
transmet de des parents aux enfants et
qui fait que les enfants sont maintenus
dans des situations défavorisés et sont
privés d'avenir les enfants racontent
leur vie et notent leurs rêves
il y a des enfants qui ont la misère
quand on n'a pas de sous on demande la
charité on down
les raisons en tout cas si il n'y a pas
de douche il n'y a pas d'eau des fois il
n'y a même pas de filtre la lumière on
ferait des sites est très solide très
solide des sites esso bout des sites est
propre avec des murs cas des balançoires
et très beau et très beau jardin
[Musique]